Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
Okay
What if I started doing that?
What if I tried to introduce that?
I've gotten it in a few different places.
I mean why are we still
talking about this intro?
It's old news now.
No, but I almost changed it.
If there's something freeing
about just letting something,
just go, you can do it on your part.
You can't change it,
No I don't wanna change it.
until you've established.
Just I'm -
And you've messed with it so much.
Sometime in the,
as you explain what we're
too gonna to talk about,
just hold out a vowel.
Holding out a vowel brings
health and vitality.
And who are you?
I'm Rhett.
And this week at the round
table of dim lighting,
oh, and I'm Link.
See you messed me up.
Yeah.
Unless we say,
It was all a test.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're talking about, what
are we talking about?
We're gonna be answering some questions.
You know, we've been talking
about a lot of things
about trips and preparation for trips.
And we've been, you know,
arguing about things.
Just gonna shoot the breeze today.
We're gonna just talk about some things.
I mean, it may get heavy
and you know you never know.
It may get heavy, that's
what we should have said.
It should've been welcome to Ear Biscuits.
It may get heavy.
But the general disposition
Is that it'll be light.
Is that it's light, we come in light.
Very light
Very light.
But then things started
getting a little saturated
and we get heavy.
I gotta give an update
on my medical condition.
Okay, how's it getting
heavy right from the top?
I suffered an injury.
I tangled with wildlife
and messed up my face.
I saw this yesterday.
For a number of days.
On the video chat.
I actually started getting scared.
Christy confessed last night
as we were going to sleep,
she was like, you know I
got a little scared that
you were never gonna be the same.
That your face was gonna
look like that forever?
Yeah, she was like,
you might have to wear a
mask when we make love.
I was gonna think about that.
And I was like,
yeah I could wear a mask of
what my face used to look like.
This is the conversation we had last night
while falling asleep.
And I think that's the
moment I fell asleep.
I was like, yeah,
I would just wear a mask of my own face
of what I used to look like.
That raises some interesting questions
that we can discuss a
little bit later like.
A mask work? I've never
done any mask work.
No, I mean,
That's what you're asking.
Not to make it a serious unnecessary.
Not to make it heavier
I get you.
But like there, it happens
quite often, not quite often,
but it isn't uncommon
for like one of the
people in a relationship
to undergo some sort of transformation.
Like sometimes it can be extreme.
Like the woman who had her face torn up
by a chimpanzee.
Oh gosh.
No I'm saying for real.
And then she had to get a face transplant.
So I guess what I'm saying is that
I don't know if she was in
a relationship at the time,
but like to think that,
you know I'm not throwing
Chris under the bus.
I know she was probably
joking, but you know,
I don't think you can,
I don't think that-
She was joking.
To put on a mask.
I think it's to find
acceptance in the new face.
Yes, of course, I mean, yeah, I wasn't,
I didn't take it personally.
Well, I mean, I immediately fell asleep.
I was not, I didn't take
it to mean anything.
While you had a running with wildlife,
it was not nearly as serious
as a running with a chimp.
It was, not to minimize it,
but I did notice it on
our video call though.
I know you did.
And that was many hours
later just, okay, so let me,
let me tell the story.
So I went mountain biking
on a Saturday morning
and we're near the end of our ride.
And well first of all,
we're like trucking up this,
I'll call it a mountain, more like hills.
But a lot of uphill,
and a lot of working, working, working
and then finally get to the top
and then you've got a lot of
downhill on these single tracks
and some of it's quite sandy.
And Nick who I go with
he's faster than me.
I never like to go in front
when we're going downhill.
I always let him go
first, go at his own pace.
I don't want him breathing down my neck
and forcing me to go
faster than I wanna go.
Has he got his new fancy bike yet?
He got his new fancy bike.
So he's going even faster.
He's going to even faster,
he's got dual suspension
and I still got the hard tail.
So my butts
I just don't think I can-
taking a beating.
I'm too worried.
Not about what
Too tall.
happened to you.
But I'm just worried about,
What?
Add this to the list.
So I'm coming down the single
track and I took a wrong turn.
And then I finally got
back on the trailing,
caught up with Nick
who was waiting for me.
And then to finish out the
run, I went ahead of him
and like two minutes
of going ahead of him,
just trying to get the end
of the run taken care of
I'm going faster than I actually wanna go.
'Cause like just subconsciously
I don't wanna be like the chump that's
slowing somebody down.
And I hit this sand patch
and my wheel turns to the left
but the bike keeps going straight.
Yeah.
And there's this moment
where everything slows down
and you're like well,
I'm I gonna fight this
or I'm I just gonna fall
in the most controlled way possible?
Which I elected to do.
You fell?
Oh yeah, I went off of the bike
in front of the bike
This is why I'm not going.
I hit the ground and did
like a stunt man roll.
And in the back of my mind,
And you don't have on
like pads or anything?
No, it was sandy.
I could have hit a rock,
but not with my head,
but with my shoulder or
something, yeah it could have.
I did a stunt man role
and part of it was not to injure myself
and part of it was to kind
of look cool and purposeful
'cause I knew I was being watched
by Nick who was coming up behind me.
You know and not that he gives a crap
or that I give a crap that I
fell off the bike or you know.
But still subconsciously
you don't wanna look-
Well you're fine, you
gotta land into something.
You gotta target into something.
So then I'm like, I'm fine.
I get right back on the bike
and I let him go first.
Yeah.
And then we get down and we,
exit off the single track
and we're on this fire road going
the rest of the way to exit out.
We're going pretty fast,
but we're it's no longer
treacherous territory.
So my guards down and that's
when I get hit in the forehead
with a bug of some sort.
And I'm like, dang, that
was a hard bug kind of.
I mean, like a windshield
Exoskeleton.
And then I realized I feel
a crawling that's happening,
like under my sunglasses
in between my eyebrows.
So I instinctively,
You've got sunglasses? You
got like bike sunglasses?
I had these
Like NASCAR.
Prescription sport sunglasses.
That's tight.
They're Oakleys
and they look really stupid.
But you know what,
They're like mascara.
but they are the best.
But they are really light and they-
From the practical side.
Yeah that's where I got 'em.
I hate that they became
associated with a certain
Well they're, yeah.
I think they're the best glasses.
I wish I could make them look good
because when you put on
like cool sunglasses,
they let too much light in the sides
and you can't really see.
Yeah.
You put on those Oakleys
that are like numb
and I'm going to a NASCAR race.
Like you can see everything.
And they're not the most
aggressive tint either
so I can wear them
They're so light.
in lower light 'cause I need them for
the prescription.
They don't hurt your face.
And I'd rather not wear my normal glasses
like I'm wearing right you know.
Well they don't protect you from
what you're about to tell us.
Yeah so it's like, I feel the crawliness,
and I'm still trucking down the road.
And so I just grabbed
the arm of the sunglasses
and I just yanked them off of my face
and then like throw them down behind me.
Like I don't throw the
glasses down, but I like,
I try to,well how would you
describe that for the listeners?
Just kinda jerk,
Jar them off, fling.
Jar the insect off.
So I fling it yeah.
Yeah.
I fling the glasses in
order to get the thing off.
And then I flung pretty aggressively
and I'm still peddling
pretty aggressively.
And then I just slammed
my glasses back on my face
and I got stung by a bee
right in between my eyes.
Like not in between my eyebrows,
right in between my eyes right there.
Did it not
On the bridge of my nose,
cross your mind to inspect the glasses.
Like you flung,
but then just-
I flung so hard.
There was no way I thought
there's no way this bee
or bug or whatever it was could be-
Can hold on to anything like.
Well yeah they can.
Just look at it.
Oh, he's still there but.
I'll do
Do that next time.
I'll do that next time because
let me tell you it hurt.
And I was like, I just got stung by a bee.
I was like, oh shit and then
I like stopped you know,
And that bee died for you.
But he thought he was protecting
his colony or something.
His colonies are like 300
yards behind at this point.
I mean, I knew I got stung it did hurt,
but it didn't hurt that bad.
But then a few seconds went by
and it started hurting a lot more.
Face is a bad place to get stung.
I mean, it could've stung me
right on the eyelid or the eye ball.
The eyeball.
It could have.
If it was crawling right
in front of the lens,
when I slammed it back on my face
and my eyes are open.
You would have closed your eye.
I bet you it could happen, but
I think it's pretty unlikely.
You would have gotten out not stung.
You know what happens if you get
Stung in the eye in the ball.
In the ball of the eye.
I don't think an eyeball can swell
Probably doesn't even hurt.
Yeah.
It's probably awesome.
Probably can't even feel it.
That makes you see better.
Probably like man what is that?
I see a fuzzy bee really up close.
It's stuck permanently to my eyeball
till I blink it off.
The pain spikes after a few
seconds, as it turns out.
And then it sent an immediate
headache across the whole,
stratus of my head.
When was the last time
you got stung by a bee?
It's hard to remember Rhett.
When you had a bee beard?
Is that the last time?
I think that was it, yeah.
When we did the 50,000
bees all over my face,
and then after you blew
them off with a leaf blower,
one of them was clinging to my neck.
It was 10,000 but 50,000
does sound better.
Okay let's say 50,000.
And it probably wasn't 10,000,
but that's pretty good.
And now that one didn't
hurt that bad on my neck.
Yeah next landed on his face.
It was like a glancing sting.
Also that was a different bee.
Those were juvenile calm bees.
And I think they probably,
I don't know, maybe they
don't have much as a stinger.
This one was so wild man
and aggressive.
Could've been a killer bee.
So I'm like, well let's get the,
one of those murder hornets that's around?
No just like an Africanized bee.
So I was like, well, let's
just get back to the car
before my whole face swells up.
But by the time I got back to the car,
which is like maybe 15 minutes later,
You were on your way back?
Yeah, yeah.
If you hadn't been on your way out,
would you have turned
around and gone back home?
No.
Okay.
'Cause I'm not allergic to bees.
It's not that big of a deal, you know.
But then
by the time I got back
the pain was subsiding
and I was like, okay, fine.
Now the thing I didn't do that
I wish I would have done was
inspected to see if there was a stinger
and then like try to like scrape it out
with my fingernail or something.
Just to make sure that
it wasn't still in there.
And then eat it which like I did
when they took this
thing out of my brother,
when I was a kid I don't know why.
It's like a ceremonial rite of passage.
I was just sitting there
watching my parents take it out.
They put it on a paper towel.
I was like, I'm gonna
eat that, and I ate it.
It was so weird.
I know I eat everything, but
it's just such a weird choice.
Yeah, that is weird.
I'll eat the stinger.
And then they were like,
what happened to it?
And I was embarrassed,
I was like, oh I ate it.
You were embarrassed.
I don't know why, It was super impulsive.
Wow, that's strange.
I don't do that many things like that.
I don't just eat things
that aren't edible,
unless I'm being paid.
You must have been starving.
You must have been absolutely starved.
It wasn't for hunger.
It was so strange.
I think maybe I thought it would be like a
honeysuckle or something.
Is that what the honey comes out of?
It's like you got a honey nozzle.
You wanted to suck all the honey maker.
I think maybe I took it and was like,
I'm gonna suck the honey out of it.
And then I just ended up eating.
I know that's not how honey works okay.
I know but I was like five.
I wanna suck the honey out of it.
There's gotta be some
It's venom.
residual honey in there.
I know it's a completely
different part of the body.
I mean, it's when a bee stings you,
it's not injecting you with that.
I know, the honey is just
comes from the stomach
and they spit it out.
Oh man.
Honey is bee vomit, the
other end of the bee.
And they don't die when
they give it to you.
So I drove home, I told
the family the story.
I didn't think much about it.
You know, that was, I mean,
like nine o'clock in the morning
That evening, it was just, you know,
it's just a normal Saturday.
That night I stayed up till like 1:00 AM.
I started to notice that, like,
there was a red line when I
would take my glasses off.
But I just thought my
glasses had been on my face.
You know, I just wasn't concerned.
And I go into bed that late,
I was planning on sleeping late,
but then I woke up at
like 6:30 in the morning
kind of frustrated but like,
even before my eyes were totally open,
I could tell that like
out of the bottom of my
periphery like you're laying down
and you're kinda looking, you know,
trying to see what time it is
without opening your eyes all the way.
I noticed that all I could see was flesh.
When you can see yourself,
you know, something's up.
Yeah I was like-
You could see your own face.
And then I immediately got scared
and I didn't want to wake up Christy
'cause I didn't wanna scare her.
But I went downstairs and
I went to the bathroom
and I, I mean, that's the
first picture I took and-
That's in the morning?
That was in that morning so,
and it got worse than that right.
But like I tried to take like a video
where like you could
really see that it was-
What is the redness on there?
The redness on the right
side of the bridge of my nose
is where it stung me.
And then it's just that
redness is just swelling.
And then it's starting to swell.
The eye gap.
You know the flesh on
the bridge of your nose
in between your eyes but
like below your eyebrows
I call that the eye gap, that
started to really swell up.
And then
my cheek started to swell out
right under my eye as well.
And then-
It doesn't so much-
Later on that day I tried, you know.
It kept swelling and I took a selfie
'cause I was gonna send it
to Nick and tell him like,
remember that bee sting.
And then I took that one
and then I was like, nah,
I'm gonna take one where I smile.
Because I don't wanna look miserable.
That doesn't look like a smile.
That was a smile.
Are you allergic to me
talking about bee sting?
Well the funny thing is,
it doesn't strike me.
Because of the way it's
so perfectly symmetrical,
it doesn't strike me
as you with an injury.
It strikes me as a different
person who actually-
With a F, a F
Yes.
Like a fat nose,
Like,
Bridge.
It's not-
And when I put on my glasses,
it covers most of it up
so you really can't tell.
You look almost the same.
I look kinda normal.
But I was kinda scared and I
looked it up and I was like.
You know, is this gonna close my airway?
I'm I gonna have a
major allergic reaction?
Not a day later.
Yeah not a day later.
It was what they call a moderate reaction.
Which is I wasn't having any hives
or any other reaction anywhere else
except right where it stung me.
And then I felt better when I read
from the Mayo Clinic that,
you know, it would be 24
to 48 hours of swelling
before it goes away.
And of course, this is now
the third day and it's,
I'm looking pretty normal again right?
But what's today? Tuesday.
Yeah.
You know it's interesting because,
I was already under the impression that,
and we talked about this before
that you look different without glasses
than you used to look without glasses.
Yeah.
That like,
you wearing glasses for
an extended period of time
has done a very slight something
to the bridge of your nose.
Has it?
That makes you but now I don't know
if just I'm seeing the residual bee sting.
But I've thought that for years that like,
Whenever I-
You started wearing
glasses in like 2005 or six
or something like that.
Yeah.
And then like seven or eight years-
It's more of my face
into it, I was like,
oh Link looks a little bit
different than he used to look.
I mean you also have
aged eight or nine years.
But like can that happen?
Is my nose bridge starting
to slouch because of.
It's not slouching,
Under the support of glasses.
It's very slightly wider.
Wider? What's wider?
Yeah.
Right here in between your eyes.
No, no, no it ain't wider man.
That's from the bee sting.
Right now that's what I'm saying.
For right now that's what it is but,
it's definitely the bee sting right now.
'Cause it's not all the way down.
When you take your glasses off, I'm like.
That doesn't look like
Link without glasses.
That looks like a very
slightly different person.
Yeah and it's like,
kind of like my dad too.
My dad doesn't wear glasses.
I'm starting to look more like my dad.
But when I came home, I
mean, when the kids woke up,
they couldn't look at me.
They were like so
freaked out they're like,
dad you looked like a different person.
And Lily was like, you look like,
in the movie Avatar
Yeah.
when like the guy goes under
and then he becomes his
avatar and they kind of,
it looks like the guy,
except the space in
between his eyes is bigger.
Yeah 'cause they almost make their eyes
look like cat like.
What happens on a cat's face, right here.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a little bit wider.
Fat nose bridge.
And yeah.
I got the avatar I don't know if-
It's not as much well,
It's not that much right now.
You know once a month we
do like a company-wide
zoom call and Link was a little
bit more swollen yesterday.
And he was telling the story
and he like showed himself.
And then Emily said that he
looked like the baby man mask.
That I wear.
That you wore on the,
I guess the first time you wore-
'Cause it's got a wide nose bridge too.
Yeah and I was like,
yeah that's exactly what it looks like.
Yeah so, I mean,
I'm sure that Chrissy would
be fine sorting mail with me
in the long-term, but in the short term,
she was joking but I mean,
there's some truth in a joke.
Maybe I need a mask.
Like I need to make a mask if
when my face goes back to totally normal,
I need to go ahead and make a mask of it.
It could also be
something that we give away
to the mythical society.
We could give away, like.
Well, you know they made those like
hyper realistic old people.
Halloween masks of us.
They're like, you know,
they made of like silicon
or something, silicone,
whatever the correct word is for that
and then they, the way
they fit around the eyes
is like really perfect.
Yeah.
Like I wonder how much it
costs to get one of those made.
Like, that would be crazy to get.
Very creepy, but kind of cool.
How come and I'm sure this does exist.
Doesn't that exist?
Don't they make like
that old man mask that
you see people wearing
and it really legitimately
seems to transform them into an old man.
Are there celebrities
that you can just become
or is that a bad idea?
Because then people will
just become those celebrities
and do heinous things.
It doesn't look that real.
Have you see one of those things?
I mean are you talking about
like Mission Impossible,
like Tom cruise ripping off-
Just recently on Twitter I saw
a dude just put one of
the old man masks on
and like pull his collar
up above the thing.
And it's just like,
But you have to glue around the eyes-
No, it's fitted to his eyes, I think.
Oh really?
And so of course the old
person thing works because
their eyes are a little bit, you know,
more sunken and like
fleshy around there anyway.
So like you just see like an extra fold
and you don't really
Oh.
think about what it is.
Maybe we should have had these masks.
Old man version of Renton Lake.
No we're becoming old men.
Yeah.
So let's just get the masks
made now, mythical dot com.
Well we'll march it up.
So I'm feeling relief
that this morning a, the air
quality was better you know.
At least the
It was weird though.
Yesterday morning, it smelled
like smoke in the morning.
But then the air quality,
but then it looked fine.
I don't know.
There's like three different things.
This morning was great
and my nose was normal-ish.
Sometimes it's smoky, sometimes it's ashy,
and sometimes it just smells
like smoke, but it's clear.
I don't understand.
And today was the first
time it was like totally
in the green and quiet.
Seemed normal.
You know what, I appreciated
it for the first time.
I was like, I'm walking
around, I'm in Los Angeles,
but I'm free to breathe for once.
You know, it's the little things.
Once they're taken away, because
the whole place is burning.
So I'm feeling good.
I'm feeling like
I'm glad you're okay.
I'm back to my norm, back to myself.
Of course, then I get in here
and I'm waiting for you to get here
and I'm trying to do
something on a computer and I,
my day gets ruined again.
I don't know if we can talk
about that if you want to,
but I don't know if you want me to go.
If you can withstand some negativity.
Oh well, let's see.
We might come back to that
if it naturally occurs.
We're now gonna answer
some of your questions.
But first we're gonna
remind you that we have
grooming products.
We stay relatively well-groomed.
This week you know,
I mean,
speaking of chimpanzees.
Think about how much I care about my face.
That's all I've talked about
for the past 15 minutes.
Yeah so if you care about your face
your body,
fixing your hair, your skin
and your.
We've got things that can make that
Your beard.
better for you,
Your beard, your lips,
your hair, grooming.
And if you want the
things that we have now,
we will not have them forever
Right?
In the current that they're in.
And some things may be going
away forever, so I'm just,
we're just giving you this
subtle warning that like,
if you're into the grooming
products and you wanna make sure
that you have some of these for posterity
and maybe some of it
it's just because you really
liked the current packaging,
then I would say gobble
it up, mythical.com.
I will note that I'm wearing the shirt
that you wore of mine on the podcast
Yeah.
a couple of episodes ago.
Your shirt that became my shirt.
And I just wanted to demonstrate that.
I wasn't wearing your shirt.
When I was wearing it
in my mind it was my shirt,
you had given it to me.
Well here's the thing
I have.
And then you took it back.
I have given you some shirts because
some shirts are like
borderline too small for me
and then they get washed
and then they become too small right.
But because I have a precedent,
there's a little bit of
a precedent doing that,
sometimes my shirts
get put into your area.
I know you didn't give me the shirt now.
Right.
But I did think you
gave me the shirt then.
But this shirt is not too small so.
I don't know how I ever wore that shirt
now that I see it I mean.
It's almost too big for me.
It fits you just right.
Yeah I was actually experimenting
with wearing larger shirts
and now I'm done with that.
Oh that one's, I mean.
Is this one larger?
That one is larger,
I mean,
It's larger down here.
we both went through a
tight shirt phase but
I'm going back.
Your tight shirt phase
was so much too.
Yeah too much.
Did you see the rock?
Yes.
So,
Yeah well what was up with that tightness?
Well, he did his like
endorsement of Biden and Harris famously,
independently, political.
The Rock came out and supported
Biden and in the video,
He had on half a shirt.
There's some of the things
people have said about
this shirt and like how
he gets it on, it's like.
I think it was Eddie from,
you know, Gus and Eddie.
He like tweeted, breaking
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson
endorses the tightest shirt of all time.
Which it just struck me as
Yeah it was a bit strange.
But he almost looks like the grapes from
Fruit of the Loom, you
know like his muscles.
Packs.
His packs and his,
everything is so developed.
Wow.
And then it was like so tight.
And then somebody observed,
how does he wear a shirt this tight
and you can't see even
a hint of his nipples?
Oh, really? I haven't looked.
I was like man you can't see the nipples.
And he's like 'cause it's a video.
I think 'cause he puts,
You think he tapes
he puts tape over.
tape his nipples?
Puts tape over 'em.
I think he just has really
small, soft nipples.
Might have had them removed surgically
for that reason.
For the smoothness of his tight shirts.
Smoothness and tightness.
But when you see a dude
that's that muscular
wearing a tight shirt,
you kind of just like, okay,
first of all, I get it.
You know, you've got those muscles
Yeah.
might as well show them off.
Also, I assume that
it's hard to find a
shirt that like imagine.
Imagine the Rock in a shirt that fits
like the one that you have on right now.
Like how big would the shirt have to be
to like have this extra in the sleeve?
Yeah.
Like, I mean,
he would look ridiculous.
But if you go back to like, I
don't know what year it was.
I mean, what do you
think was peak tightness?
I mean, I got pretty tight,
but you got extra tight.
What was peak tightness? Like 2000 what?
The thing is-
2012, 2014?
I don't know.
I'd like to develop some sort of excuse
or rationale as to how it happened.
It was in the style.
I think it was also, I would
get really attached to shirts
and then they would shrink.
But I would really like the shirt
and then I'd keep wearing it.
Yeah I have a built-in sort of,
'Cause I get very attached.
I have a built in buffer for that
because if the shirt gets
tighter, it also gets shorter
and then it's so,
Yeah.
then it gets where I'm just like,
you can see my belly
when I reach for things
and I'm like.
That doesn't happen to me.
So I don't even have the, you know,
I don't have the option,
I gotta get long shirts.
I get long shirts, wash them
and then they become normal shirts for me.
This is an extra long shirt
which I'm surprised is why you wore it.
I feel supported in a tighter shirt.
I prefer sleeping in a tighter
shirt 'cause I feel snuggled.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah so it actually makes
me feel more secure.
It's like a dog in one of those
security blanket things where you like
when you sync a dog up
Yeah.
with something on its back.
Like a baby in a burrito
wrap, that's like me.
I didn't do it for anybody.
I didn't do it for the
look, I did it for the feel.
So it makes you feel
like you're in the womb?
Yeah, yeah.
Interesting.
Or in the loving arms of my mother.
I mean maybe your mom
had a much tighter uterus
than my mom.
I don't care to comment
on the tightness of our mothers' uteri.
Man that's messed up, man.
How big of a baby were you?
Do you know the.
I wasn't that big of a baby.
If I put a gun to your head
and I wouldn't do that.
But if I were to do
that and I want to say,
if you can't tell me how
much you weighed as a baby,
I'm gonna kill you.
I'm gonna sting you with a bee.
This is just a gun that
has a bee on the end
and Imma sting you on the face.
I'd say I was seven pounds
six ounces with confidence.
And put the gun away.
Really?
I don't know.
Yeah I don't know either,
a seven something.
Yeah I would just go for
something believable.
Let's answer some questions.
These are questions that we liked
that you asked a while
ago that we never got to.
First one comes from
Shell, the velvet hook.
Oh, here we go
A long time mythical beast.
She's got a picture of a,
Me.
You.
You're in the upper right hand.
My nose and beard is in
it, but we've got Patricia.
Okay
Patricia, Patricia.
This is after the Golden Globes, she says-
We did not go to the Golden Globes,
but we went to a Golden
Globes after party,
which we talked about on Ear Biscuits.
Right and we've done that several times.
We've gone to after parties
even wearing tuxedos.
And it makes you seem like
you went to the awards
but you didn't
because you couldn't get into the awards,
but you can get into the after party.
I think this was-
It's just a PR tactic.
This was the first and
last party that we attended
wearing tuxedos.
Which we now own because they said
don't rent the tuxedo,
you should just buy it.
That way you'll have one
whenever you need one again.
And I've never worn it again.
Well because I mean,
COVID.
COVID happened.
I mean now no one's wearing tuxes.
But this is going up against 2019.
This was like January,
it's a long time ago.
Well the question is,
I'm forever wondering
what happened at the Golden
Globes after party last year
that led to Link Neal holding Patricia,
I don't know why I can't see your name,
Arquette's award.
Y'all never said anything about it
when you talked about the
party on Ear Biscuits,
please tell us.
Does this moment that's
captured here, does it,
I mean, I'm firmly gripping
and looking down at her award.
She's making eye contact with me
and starting to grab the award.
Does it look like she's
trying to take it back
or that she's finishing handing it to me?
What is she looking at?
She's probably looking at you.
She's looking a little,
I think she's making eye contact with me.
I think she is too.
It's a little too high for you.
Yeah she's looking at me.
She's like, why are you grabbing my award?
That's not what she's thinking.
Her husband's right beside her.
Don't make this stranger than it is.
I don't know if that's her husband.
I do.
You do?
Yeah 'cause I remember that I met the guy
and I just got that vibe
that it wasn't a handler.
It wasn't like an agent or
like a, a professional person,
this is a personal person.
And the other reason is because
here's how this happened.
This is what I do remember.
Yeah.
A girl came up to us
like a teenager,
Yap.
and she was a fan and she was like,
Oh my gosh, it's so cool
seeing you guys here.
I'm a mythical beast.
And then she ended up saying,
I'm Patricia Arquette daughter.
And then
was it in the same moment
that then she walked up
or I think then she was
like, sorry, I gotta go.
And then she like followed her mom.
And I think her dad somewhere else.
Yeah this is the whole family right here.
That Harlow is the daughter.
Okay.
Shout out to Harlow, mythical beast.
But then we were mingling-
She's got quite a name,
Harlow Olivia, how do you say that?
You know you need to
preserve her privacy man.
She's a celebrity's daughter, man.
Yeah, but she's not a celebrity.
She's I think she's a,
Yeah she is.
I think she's an oter.
Okay.
So we're mingling around this party
and the best that I can recall,
we like say hello to her again.
And then we started talking to
like Patricia was talking
to a lot of people.
I mean, when you've won,
she won the Golden Globe for
best performance by an
actress in a TV movie
or mini series for Escape at Dannemora.
Which was, it's a true story
of a woman who worked at a
prison helping two guys escape.
Seems pretty cool, never saw it.
Directed by Ben Stiller.
You know a lot about this.
Well I had to look it up
because I couldn't remember any of it.
And she gave an acceptance speech.
Like a lot of it was bleeped
because she was talking about her,
her janked up fake teeth and
her janked up real teeth.
And then she was using the F-bomb a lot.
But she's a very spirited person.
And she always,
when she wins a lot of stuff
because she's super talented
and she has these famous
speeches where she like
takes a stand on issues-
She's like I'm up here, I'm
gonna take advantage of it.
She's always the talk of
the town the next day.
So even that night after she won
and had given this memorable speech,
I believe about voting actually.
Voting in 2020, ironically enough.
And voting in 2018.
No that for 2019.
So she was way ahead of the game on that.
And so a lot of people
are trying to talk to her
and get a little time with her,
but like we had an end
because of her daughter.
And then she turns around
and I don't remember what happened,
but I'm sure we said
something that made sense,
or at least you did.
And then I'm like
congratulations or something.
And I'm pretty sure I was just like,
Can I hold it?
Yeah.
I mean, how often do you get a chance
to hold a Golden Globe?
Well, I think
our only opportunity is probably gonna be,
Then.
At the after party.
at the after party
when we ask someone who won one.
Right I'm like can I hold it?
And it's like, I wonder if
anybody else asked her that?
Or does anyone ask anybody that?
It's, I mean,
It's a little,
It kinda comes full circle though.
You know what I'm saying? Because,
For a man who gets embarrassed
for falling off of his
bike in front of his friend
who doesn't give a shit,
I don't know why.
I think you get embarrassed by much.
Yeah, I wasn't-
So I think that the,
I held it, look, I'm holding
it right there, it's proof.
The instinct to ask if you can hold it,
which I completely
relate to and understand
is sort of based in, you know,
being from Harnett County right?
Because when you boil it all down,
we're just a couple of guys
who grew up in Harnett County.
Yeah.
Who the idea of a Golden
Globe is like, can I hold it?
You know what I'm saying?
'Cuase it's foreign.
I mean, by definition
it is foreign.
It is foreign.
And so, but then the difference
between me and you is
I'll think that and wonder and think,
but I don't want to
necessarily just reveal
that I'm from Harnett County.
And then you're like, well, I don't care.
But the interesting thing is
when I'm saying when it
comes full circle is that,
by actually going full circle
and asking if you can hold it,
I don't think that Patricia
Arquette thinks that,
Oh, this guy's a redneck.
I think she's just like,
Oh, this guy just, he wants
to hold the Golden Globe.
Patricia is the releast of the real.
I'm gonna hand it to him.
And I'm like, you know,
you might as well just
check our potential at
the door when you're
interacting with Ms. Arquette.
She graciously, she was like sure.
But the thing that,
And we held it
and I think I said something
about how heavy it was.
Well of course that's the
only thing you can say.
Yeah 'cause what else?
It's kind of like being
a celebrity and saying,
Yeah.
You're shorter
than I thought you'd be.
Right, right, right.
And we're gonna say this is much lighter.
It must be hollows.
Yeah this is cheap.
Is this the real one?
Yeah right.
And it was heavy.
One of the things, we
talked about this before
that we've learned about
these after-parties is
streamies are not that heavy.
The photographer,
you know there's people
going around taking pictures
and like, you wanna create these moments.
That's why we, one time we,
we fake the fight at the GQ
party or wherever it was.
And we've got a picture taken.
But the,
Look on my face.
Is that what were gonna talk about?
No, I'm just saying that,
That's a dumb look.
You holding the Golden Globe,
I'm staring at it.
You could think,
Oh this must be someone
that she really knows
and is connected to because
she's letting him hold.
You know what I'm saying?
You don't,
It kind of looks like
she's trying to my award.
You wanna tell a story.
It was like, oh this guy, who's that guy?
Did he win one?
Right.
So I'm saying that
doing these kinds of things
is ultimately a good thing
because you will get good photos taken.
Yeah, I have many people congratulate me
on my Golden Globe.
Nope, that's not true.
Let's ask another question.
So we cleared that one up Shell.
Long time coming but we did it.
1iron4
Put the rumors to rest.
1iron4, this doesn't keep me up at night.
I think 'cause we asked you guys,
is there anything that
keeps you up at night?
But that when we sleep, we just
see the back of our eyelids.
Like our eyes don't turn off or anything.
It's just covering them like sunglasses.
The way you just read that,
seemed like you were just
reading it to yourself.
Can you read it again in a way
it can makes sense to me?
Well it's not really
phrased as a question.
It's a statement.
When we sleep, we just see
the back of our eyelids.
Like our eyes don't turn off or anything.
It's just covering them like sunglasses.
I know what's up here.
For the longest time I
thought whenever I would sleep
or even just close my eyes.
I honestly thought, I'll
say as a child, okay.
That my eyes rolled in
the back of my head.
I thought that like, as
the shades came down,
the eyes rolled back.
You mean like a baby doll?
You know like if you lay one of those
baby dolls down that is what happens.
Their eyelids are weighted,
so they come out there.
There's a weight on the back
of some baby dolls eyelids,
so that when you turn it like that,
it swivels and then covers.
But the eyeball
The eyeball stays the same
on the babydoll.
Yeah I thought the eyeball
rolled back in the head.
And then,
Can you feel what that feels like though?
Because then when you open your eyes,
I mean I guess they-
When you open your eyes
after being closed for awhile,
it kind of has a sensation
of them rolling back.
Well they might go back a little bit.
That ain't true.
But they move around a lot during REM.
But no, what 1iron4 is
talking about is what you see.
So earlier on when I was a child
and I don't return to
this as much anymore.
I'll think about it but like
I just noticed it when I close my eyes,
if I really stopped and focused,
I could lock into
basically a light show that
has the sensation that I'm like
traveling through space and
seeing stars pass by me.
Like a bunch of little dots right.
And in the way to enhance this is
is if you just take your eyes
and you press on them, it
will enhance that effect.
And also potentially hurt your eyes.
No, I'm just pressing very lightly.
But then there it is, okay.
Now I have focused on this like membrane.
This does not happened to you?
No, but,
I think you haven't focused on it.
I haven't.
I think you have to see something.
I looked up an explanation for it.
And when I read the
explanation, I was like,
I've never experienced this
and it is what you described.
So let me read that explanation
and then I'll try it.
A Huffington post article.
You close your eyes and
right before you fall asleep,
he noticed something, a twinkling.
A swirling pattern of stars and colors
producing a makeshift light show
on the inside of your closed eyelids.
Yeah.
That's what you're describing.
Many people who have seen
this visual phenomenon
think it is a light induced after image
of what they had seen before
they closed their eyes
which
It's not.
I mean, if you stare at a light
or something bright and
then close your eyes,
you still see an after image.
That does happen,
But that's not at all
what I'm talking about.
And in this agrees,
but an after image may only be
part of what they are seeing.
The real reason we are treated to this
fuzzy fireworks display behind
closed lids has to do with
phosphenes P H O S P H E N E S phosphenes
are the moving visual
sensations of stars and patterns
we see when we close our eyes.
They are thought to be caused by
the inherent electrical
charges the retina produces,
even when it is in its resting state.
So it's like you're
looking at a wire that has
electricity going through it essentially.
See I just close my eyes
and I feel like I'm seeing,
I'm definitely seeing some after images.
We got some like strong light sources.
You need to cover your eyes
gently and press on your eyeballs gently.
Man I've still got swelling.
And then you have to stop.
And then there is like a,
it's very difficult to acknowledge it.
But once you acknowledge
it and focus on it,
you can actually follow like
the fabric of space
time that you're seeing
inside your eyes.
Sometimes it's really, really
easy and obvious, but hold on.
Okay there it is, I'm locked in again
and I can literally see
like this, it's like stars,
but they're super tightly packed stars.
And they're very, very faint.
And do they move?
Yes, it's like constantly moving.
Like you're moving through them.
It's very hard to
finally focus on and see,
but I did it as a kid
and ever since then I've been able to do.
I can't seem to do it.
Yeah I think you just have to like,
I think you just need some
time alone and a lot of time.
You know just-
A lot of time alone?
You need a lot of time alone because it's.
You know what it is?
It's the same exact sensation.
It's a totally different principle,
but it's the same sensation
of staring at one of those
weird things in the mall
and all of a sudden seeing it.
Oh it was there all along,
but I had to like cross
my eyes a little bit.
Like that's how it feels.
Here's something strange,
you talking about that weird guy
who would always sit in
front of mrs. Fields cookies
and like make you not want to get a cookie
'cause he was like, why is
he always on that bench?
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Yeah, yeah.
The things
that you look at where you sit.
The hidden images.
What do you call 'em?
We put one in the Book of Mythicality.
Can't remember what it's called?
Did it work though?
Did the one in the Book
of Mythicality work?
No, once we decided that
we didn't have the
capability to create one,
we made it a joke that on the next page
we revealed that there was nothing there.
Right, 'cause it's not easy to create one.
But we thought oh sure-
We did not want to spend the money,
Surely there's a company,
to hire those people.
that does this, but it's
not as easy as you think.
Well, sometimes if you're
just with your eyes open,
if you're staring, like
if you're just like
relaxing and then your eyes just kinda.
You're like your eyes open,
but you're not really using them.
See floaters,
You can start to see floaters.
And it's like, you're seeing things
on the surface of your eyeball,
Looking at a-
moving around.
Looking at a clear blue sky,
Like, I mean,
Yeah.
The funny thing is, as a
kid I already had floaters.
I guess I got more now.
But I don't sit around
and look at them anymore.
But like as a kid, I
would just look at the sky
and then I would start
following the floaters
and I would try to like move my eye
Right.
not too fast.
I can do that.
You know that's totally different thing-
'Cause it'll start drifting
and that's really your
eye drifting I think.
'Cause then when you try
to focus on it moves back.
I think that it's slowly
moving across the surface of your eye
Oh.
'cause your eye is wet.
But then if you focus on it,
it will move.
It moves with your eye.
Yeah and that's when you can start to feel
like it's on there.
But I highly recommend the phosphenes.
Just closed eye visualization.
Okay.
It's gonna get a little heavier.
Let's get a little heavier.
Okay, yeah let's do it.
Swaine, Michael Swaine.
What is the Achilles
heel of the human race?
We always talk about finding
the Achilles heel to aliens
if they came for war to
defeat them, what is ours?
And can we do anything to bolster it?
What is the Achilles
heel of the human race?
I think because my mind is still in this
largely in the same place
it was when we recorded
the last episode.
Which I know kind of ended on a downer
when I started talking about how
we're hopelessly divided as a country
and I had this hopeless feeling.
It's been weighing on me.
I think, as we get closer
to the election it's-
But by the time this comes out,
we're barreling down
Like two weeks yeah.
on the election.
So,
And who knows what will happen
between us talking about this
Between now and then.
and being that much closer.
But the rhetoric and the heated dialogue
and the people getting
into their trenches.
It is so pronounced right now.
And so I've been thinking about this like,
and just one thought I have,
I'm not gonna say this
is the Achilles heel,
but I think one of the
things that has happened.
Because I've been thinking
about like longer term,
more global things and like.
You know, it's one thing to talk about the
impending demise of democracy
in the United States.
Which,
Let's say potential.
I'd like to have some hope.
Well, I'm just saying, yeah,
the potentially impending demise.
I'm not saying it's
definitely gonna happen.
But again, when you think about
the United States, I mean,
we're still talking about.
If you think about all of human history,
we're still talking about
a very small period of time
that the United States has been around.
It's not gonna be around forever right?
What worked a generation
ago might not work now like.
But if you think about like the human race
and the history of just us
as a species and our future,
which I think is kind of the
50,000 foot view that Michael
Swaine is talking about.
Like the whole human race.
So I think that a big issue is that our
technological evolution has
outpaced our moral evolution.
So you're talking social dilemma.
Well, to me
Which I watched recently.
it's bigger than the Social Dilemma.
But yeah, the social dilemma
is like a symptom of it.
But I guess ultimately
what I'm saying is like,
it's just from a general,
like almost a mathematical
logical equation.
We've developed the ability
to destroy ourselves
before we've developed the collective will
to protect each other.
And so if we don't
continue to evolve
morally to a place where,
you know, empathy wins versus sort of this
self-absorbed group mentality.
Yep.
It will end.
As we know it, civilization will end.
I'm not saying that the
human race will go extinct.
Well I mean it-
But what we understand
human civilization to be
will not last unless
those things balance out.
Now that we have to just talk
about the Social Dilemma.
The documentary connecting the dots that
I felt like I was aware
of but it was like,
it was a nice packaging of it.
Yeah.
Of just connecting the dots between
how the information is served up to you
is so customized for you
that it's not about truth.
It's about whatever you will click on.
And that we are the commodity.
Our eyeballs are the
commodities that are being sold
to advertising.
A different product yeah.
And it felt weird to be,
you know,
In our business.
To be in the business we're in.
That we're creating content that then.
You know, we attract certain eyeballs
and then people buy that,
you know, even on this show.
So that's like, I don't wanna,
That's a whole different podcast.
That's a whole different
conversation but you know.
Just being struck with the reality of how
divisive, how customization
leads to division.
You know, when everything's just for me
and everything is
presented to each person,
whatever they will respond to the most,
not what is the most truthful
or the correct thing.
Then you get in these bubbles where
if you google,
the the things that
stand out for me is that
if you google climate change is
depending on who you are and
what Google knows about you
and where you are, who you are,
the more information they can get,
the more it's gonna fill
that in with something that
you are going to respond to.
Not something that's
going to give you facts.
Because the algorithm is-
Global warming is a hoax.
Right.
Or global warming is
is true, you know, it's just one example.
The thing that was news to
me, again, like you said.
Like, I think everybody has a
little bit of a sense of this.
That these are the
polarizing effects of like
your Facebook feeding your newsfeed.
But the google thing was striking
because you start seeing it like,
Oh yeah, this algorithm which is.
The algorithm is not programmed
with truth in mind right.
It isn't fact checking itself.
It's just like, my goal
is to keep you user
on the computer connected
online as long as possible
to expose you to as much
advertising as possible.
So it's definitely like one
of the things that happens is,
you know, some people are
super, super fear-based.
And so they're gonna just, any news
that is telling them about
all the shit that's going down somewhere
and how things are getting
really, really bad.
Like they're addicted to
that type of information.
That kind of dooms day situation.
And so they're gonna click
on those kinds of things.
And you're like, oh crap, it's like,
how have I been susceptible to this.
If you're scared, you're gonna,
if you feed off of fear, then
you're be fed more of fear.
If you're fed off of outrage or anger,
you're gonna be fed that.
On either side,
Yeah.
you're gonna be pushed
to an extreme because
that's what we respond to, extremes.
Well and the crazy thing is
if you're scared of something
being told that you shouldn't
be scared of something
is not a strategic way for an algorithm.
You don't wanna swage the fears.
You want to enhance and feed the fears.
So you wanna keep giving
you the stuff that
ah the cities are falling
apart or whatever.
And it doesn't happen to one group.
It happens to, the more
entrenched you are,
and the more involved you are
Yeah.
with the algorithms on whatever platform.
It polarizes you in both directions.
Because for me it's,
you've got people like
for years now I think.
Like Sacha Baron Cohen the
comedian, Borat you know,
has been very vocal in
sounding an alarm about this.
He's not the only one, but,
you know, it's just like,
I was like, I think he's
in an interesting position
because of how he kind
of, his entertainment
has been to psychologically
manipulate people
and expose people's true colors right.
But he's very outraged in how
people are being manipulated
without them knowing.
Yeah.
But it's not something
that, you know, okay.
It's not that fun to listen
to somebody get that upset
and it's not that, but then you.
The documentary is really well made.
It makes it a little more
palatable to explore the ideas.
But then it's kind of like
watching Super Size Me
and then saying, are you really
never gonna eat McDonald's
or fast food again, not really.
You know, it's like,
which is so entrenched.
And like we're not on Facebook
and the way that we're on
Instagram and Twitter is like,
it's professionally and it's different.
But I feel like we've
been on the outskirts of a lot of this.
And I just haven't understood
the extent to which
people will only get
information that works for them.
And so it's like, whenever you think,
how could anybody believe
fill in the blank.
I mean, all this information I'm reading,
it's a foregone conclusion
that X, Y, and Z.
And then it's like well,
because someone else is getting
a completely different set of
information and it's scary.
But I don't think you're getting that
this being the Achilles heel
of the human race right.
Well, I am
You are?
in one sense, because, you
know if you think about it-
It's the fact that you were
gonna say like, is it ego?
And I prefer if there's a tie.
Well no.
Yeah I guess what I'm getting at is,
this is not unexpected at all right.
So if you think about the
history of humankind like
we actually have not adapted
to believe truth right?
In fact, it's more strategic
from a natural selection
evolutionary standpoint
to believe things that aren't true.
In fact, I think it was in Sapiens
where he explains this
really, really well.
Where he just talks about
like, as a matter of fact
our ability to believe
things that aren't true,
that are kind of outside
of the natural realm
to kind of hold onto a
thought, an ideological idea
is what enabled us to kind of
come together and do things.
But we're always coming together
at the expense of another group of people.
So take it like two examples,
like you've got two villages.
It's more advantageous
for my village to believe
things that are not true
about your village.
And also to believe
things that are not true
about my own village.
Because if I'm trying to pass my genes on
and my village wants to
win versus your village.
It's like, I'm gonna make
things up about your village.
Like they're nasty, they
believe crazy stuff,
they deserve to die.
And if I can believe that then I can go
and I can feel justified
in killing them right.
And we're kind of seeing
a version of that.
We're not necessarily,
I mean, people are killing each other.
But the more common thing is
people are just completely
riding off a whole group of people
and thinking certain things about them,
having all kinds of
assumptions about them.
And then feeding themselves
with all this information
that makes them feel better
about being able to believe
that and kind of perpetuates it.
So if it gets back to this
idea of like our technology,
I mean, you could say things like well,
we develop the ability to
literally destroy our planet.
Like flute nuclear weapons right.
Before we developed a respect
and an empathy for one another
where we wouldn't be the enemy.
'Cause what did we do?
We developed a nuclear
weapon and then we used it
on a population.
We dropped two atom bombs on two cities.
Like within a couple of, you know,
decades after, I can't remember,
I don't know the timeline,
not that many years after
developing the technology
it was used.
And it's a wonder that it
hasn't been used again.
But I mean, listen, I go back to.
And you've got these
really smart computer dudes
who've just like created
these algorithms in order to
engage people and connect people socially.
And it, but it has all
these, they're not, I mean,
you see the hearings.
You see Mark Zuckerberg
at the hearings it's like
deer in headlights, but
people come into grips with,
and I haven't read all the
articles about it, but, you know,
Jack Dorsey or whatever
the head of Twitter is,
and like the journey
that he's gone on like.
Finding yourself in this position of
you've created this thing, which
may very well be a monster.
Then it's like, that's not
what you set out to create.
And it's, but now you have
that amount of power like,
it's like, it's scary.
Yeah.
And it is comparable, it's comparable.
I think it's a huge piece of it.
Like, yeah, it's exactly
what I'm saying like.
The technological advance
to be able to connect the world
in this way that seems so promising,
but yet you're connecting
people who haven't
morally evolved.
We haven't morally evolved to
a place where we can actually
be more interested in the
interest of another person
than ourselves.
Like we haven't gotten there yet.
And you know, you tell-
So, selfishness and,
I'm trying to pinpoint that Achilles heel.
And just trying to
To me,
pinpoint what you're saying.
I'm just saying
ultimately, it's the pacing
of the technology getting
ahead of the moral evolution.
Because I do think that there
is a place that I, you know.
I think the natural, it seems to me
that the natural sort of
progression of humanity,
even though,
especially from like the
background that we come from,
like an evangelical christian mindset
is what we were raised in.
And the narrative is that
things are getting worse.
It's one of the reasons that
evangelical christians
tend to be conservative
because there is this idea
that things used to be good
and the world is in decay.
And things are moving
towards the end times
up until the point where
Jesus will come back.
So things are getting worse as you go.
Whereas a progressive mentality is
actually things used to be pretty shitty.
Like people got killed
all the time by each other
and by disease and, you know,
as time has gone on we've
actually gotten things
have gotten better for more people.
Steven Pinker has a great book about this
that kind of explains how things
have actually gotten better
just by the raw numbers.
Things are moving
towards more connectivity
and more equality for more people, right.
I mean, it's tough to get there.
But I just think that we
haven't gotten to a place
where we can really put ourselves
in someone else's shoes.
And now, it'd be one thing
if we got to a place where
it was like, yes, we were super empathetic
and we were cooperative
and we saw ourselves
as one human race.
We saw ourselves as
stewards of the planet.
And then we develop the
ability to be interconnected.
Like the things that we
could do would be amazing.
But we haven't gotten there yet.
I mean, think about this is 2020.
We've known the science
behind global warming
for decades now, right?
It's relatively simple science.
It's that
very small changes in the
concentration of carbon dioxide
and methane in the atmosphere
and other greenhouse gases
leads to more retained heat.
It's complex,
but the overall principle
is pretty simple, right?
And lots of people sounding the alarm.
Seeing all kinds of the beginnings
of like more and more evidence
building in this direction.
Everyone who looks at this as
seeing more and more evidence.
But yet there's a whole group of people,
including the president who are saying
that this is not happening, right.
They're saying this is not happening.
And in fact, this is a
government's attempt to overreach
and control and all this stuff.
And the amount of misinformation
around this issue,
that could be the only thing that matters
a hundred years from now.
It could be, I hope it isn't.
And it's hard not to see that
as just trying to protect.
The people entrenched on that side,
trying to protect something
that they want to hold onto dearly
that benefits them personally.
And maybe that's an oversimplification
by being on the other side of the issue.
Well here's what I would say.
To me, it doesn't like
you don't even have to
get into the science of global warming
to like be pro green technology.
I mean, like, if you just
think about it logically,
if you think about, we
currently are based in a system
that is taking advantage
of a finite resource
that took millions of years to develop.
And we're depleting it in
a couple of generations.
Like, it doesn't matter.
Even if global warming wasn't a thing
transitioning to
primarily renewable energy
would be a no freaking brainer.
And we'd be like, who
knows what's gonna happen.
Maybe we're gonna get hit
by an asteroid someday,
and we're gonna go into a
nuclear winter for a few years
and we're gonna need to burn this coal
and need to burn this oil.
We need to hold onto it.
The only thing that you can point to
and again, this is somebody,
I was a evangelical christian,
conservative for most of my adult life
or a good portion of my adult life.
And so when I thought about
the issue of global warming,
the only thing I thought about was
I'm not supposed to
believe that that's real.
Because it's not
consistent with my ideology
and my platform.
I can't believe that that's real because
that's some sort of conspiracy
that's just designed
for the government to
take control of everyone.
And so did I ever stop
and think, but like.
So in other words, I
was allergic to actually
investigating it and looking into it.
I was allergic to any sort
of viewpoint that might be
the opposite of what
I thought at the time.
You're saying you had a blind allegiance.
I think the thing that's
difficult is that, I mean,
if you look at the COVID experience
in the United States and
you look at how poorly,
you look at the numbers compared
to the rest of the world.
And there's few countries that rival
the number of deaths that
we've had, it's just, I mean,
It's not as simple as,
we as Americans just
haven't been willing to
place the greater good
above our own current needs.
I mean it's personal needs
or wants or desires
for freedom or ideology
or whatever the reasons are.
That is true for sadly, a
bunch of people, I think.
But then there's also
these people who are like,
their livelihood depends on it.
When you think about like
a dependence on fossil fuels
yeah you got all of this money.
The most profitable business
in the history of our planet
is the fossil fuel industry.
But then you've got people,
By far.
Working class people who
their livelihoods depend on
this industry, you know.
And so you've got to address,
that has to be part of
what's addressed in order to,
to get through.
To get through COVID, to stem
the tide of climate change
is that there are people
who are in dire straits,
or will be as a result
of the necessary changes
to stem the tide of our own decimation.
And a lot of people, it's just like,
I gotta survive tomorrow.
Yeah it's a very short-term
mentality for sure.
But it's sad when you zoom out that
it's really driven by the ultra rich.
Who are fueled by and
fueling these industries
when it comes to climate change.
Manipulating the conversation
and manipulating the information
and making it seem like,
well there's a debate here right.
And I mean, I think that's
true a lot of the big issues,
when you look at healthcare,
if you look at like universal health care
and you're like,
why wouldn't anyone want
everyone to be able to get
treatment when they needed it? You know.
It's like, well, it's just a
lot more complicated in that.
And that's a sad reality,
but that doesn't,
I'm not saying that it's not
complicated I'm saying it is,
but that doesn't change the fact that
well at a certain point,
we have to band together
to do the right thing.
And unless we do, these
things will never change.
That's what's so sad is that
it's gonna take all of us, right.
I mean it's-
Well,
Because the change is,
You know.
happening at such an accelerated pace.
It's gonna take a
majority of us, you know.
Well if unless democracy
completely collapses.
At that point, and in
some senses in America
that has already happened
and it has been the case.
It's like the people with
money, they're in control,
and they're manipulating the conversation
and have a very
much higher influence
in the conversation so.
But yeah, you know,
I like saw the thing where
the governor of California,
Gavin Newsom was talking about,
okay I mean he's got this
executive order where you know.
We're gonna ban the sale of
gas powered cars by 2035.
And he didn't say he was gonna
ban gas powered cars period.
If you have one, you can still drive it.
But the sale of new cars
in 15 years from now.
And,
And just cars like small.
'Cause industrial, like farm vehicles,
trucks, and stuff like that it's 2045.
Like I said, we're giving
them 25 years to get on board.
Now predictably
but still like so sad
saddening to me is like
the response, like nine
out of 10 responses
to this on Twitter are, this guy is crazy.
This is incredibly crazy.
So what we got, is we've
got a situation where
I hope that they're wrong,
but the people who know a
lot more about this than I do
are telling me that I should
be worried about this, right.
That I should care about what's happening.
This is what's happening on earth.
And this is what could happen on earth,
If we don't do anything about this.
And then somebody in a
position of power says,
all right, well, here's
what I'm going to do.
And then he's just, he's
treated as an idiot.
So until, those people
are never gonna go away.
There's always gonna be people
who are like gonna just,
you know, not believe, you know.
Maybe a hundred years from now
when there's absolutely no doubt that
climate change happened and that
the humans were responsible
for the vast majority of this
particular portion of it,
in this point in history,
it'll just be like,
yeah there used to be people
who said it wasn't happening.
Yeah, I mean, they were wrong.
It's so frustrating
But,
Why can't we just have
a conversation about
how we're going to deal with it
and not if it exists or
if we should deal with it.
It's maddening.
But the real question is,
is a hundred years from now
have things changed so drastically.
I mean, I'm an optimist.
As much as I might seem like a pessimist.
I do think then I'm like,
surely they're gonna figure this out.
Like technology like
they're gonna find some way
to get the carbon out of the air.
We're gonna transition
to green technology.
We're gonna look back and be like,
Yeah there was this weird
time in the early 2000s
where like everybody was confused
about what was happening.
There was all this misinformation.
There was this weird thing
happening with social media.
People were confused and
nobody knew what was going on,
but we got through it
Yeah, it's just like,
and it gets pretty bad.
once we have a vaccine for COVID
everyone's gonna forget
about the whole mask fiasco.
You know, I don't wanna
have to wear a mask because
I'll just wait for the vaccine.
You know, it's like, and I
feel like we're in a position,
we're in a privileged position.
You know, because we're well off,
we're privileged and it look
at it from almost any angle.
And I just
Yeah.
you know there's, to me
honestly, I feel like,
maybe this just exposes me
for like a lot of critique,
but I feel like it.
I'm in a bit of a more objective
place because you know,
I'm not going paycheck to paycheck.
My livelihood is not directly
tied to a certain ideology.
I mean, us talking like
this, we may lose fans,
but we're not being threatened.
I don't understand why.
And I think that's why celebrities
like movie stars and people are like,
who when they speak out,
people will say things like
just shut up and be a basketball player,
or just shut up and be an actor you know.
You get to a point of
privilege where you can say,
I have so much money.
I think these superstars
like Leonardo DiCaprio
or George Clooney, they have so much money
that they can actually say, you know what?
I can actually do the right thing.
I can afford to do the right thing.
And I don't think that's
why they're doing it,
but it's like, to me,
you can listen to those people
who are saying these things,
because they're trying
to do the right thing.
That's the skin they have in the game.
And I feel for the people who, you know,
it's hard for them to do the right thing,
because it directly
affects their livelihood.
Like are they gonna get another paycheck
or something like that.
And then you got the people
who have all the money,
who aren't doing the right thing.
Who are only thinking about themselves.
I think there's a stark
contrast there and so.
Well, and there's also you know.
And we saw this
when we told our deconstruction
story it's like, you know.
We have one perspective on
the world that we came from
and the world that we're in right now.
Well people who are still
in that world are like,
well you guys are in a cult
now, you know what I'm saying?
Like you guys had it right.
You were in the right place.
You had the right mentality,
the right ideology.
And then for personal reasons you know,
because you wanted fame and fortune,
and you knew that you had to adopt these
liberal mindset and be vocal about it
in order to receive the
blessings of the masses.
And of Hollywood, you
had to do these things.
So you guys are just following a script,
a very predictable script.
And that's the only reason
that you talk about this stuff
in the way that you talk about it now.
And for someone who believes that,
which I would have believed that,
at this one point in my life.
I can't say anything
that's gonna be convincing.
There's nothing that I can say.
If I can say, well, the reason that I left
the place that I was in,
what I was actually concerned about truth.
And I feel like I followed
the evidence in the data
to a different place.
Now, I'm I some fricking robot
who only makes decisions
based on data? No.
I'm still part of the human race.
I'm still susceptible
to the group mentality.
to buying into ideology.
I'm still susceptible to
buying into a whole platform.
Yes I'm still susceptible to
feeling like I have to say something
just to make people feel like
I believe the right thing.
It's like, yes, I'm still a human.
But because I came from a place that was,
the ideology was very strong
and it was very developed
and the thinking was very systematic
and there was a herd mentality.
I became uncomfortable with that.
And I was like, I kind of feel like
I'm being told to believe
a certain set of things,
because this is what makes
it all seem to fit together
and makes us all feel connected.
But like, I actually feel like
some of it's not true guys.
And what ended up doing is I
ended up getting out of that.
And so.
Which is why I now worship Bill Gates.
So Jesse and I,
The guy who can.
Yeah we're really
sensitive to this because
I don't want I'm really,
this is why politically
I'm an independent.
I'm not a registered Republican
or a registered Democrat.
And I'm not saying that
as like a point of pride,
but for me it's like a principle.
Because I'm like, I don't
want to jump out of this camp
that's basically supported and sort of
bolstered by ideological thinking,
and then just move into this other camp.
And again, this may sound like,
oh, well, you've done that.
But I try to be as
critical of it as I can.
But when it comes to this, like
the issue of climate change,
which again, I think is sort
of supersedes, it might not.
But if what they're saying is true
then it does supersede everything else.
And it is sort of the
problem of our generation
and the biggest threat
humanity's ever faced.
And the one thing that we
actually need to agree on
and tackle together.
I'm in the boat that's like, all right,
what if it's not as bad as they're saying?
What if it doesn't happen?
Like what does coming together
and working together on a problem.
Like, how does humanity coming together?
How is it bad?
It doesn't make sense to me.
Like I'm not threatened by unity
in the way that I used to be.
Like the idea of like our
borders not being that important
and coming together this
whole idea of like one world.
Like I actually, I'm
encouraged by that now.
'Cause I think it's the
only hope for humanity.
I don't think that this let's separate,
let's build the walls, let's
differentiate ourselves.
Like we've already seen what that does.
That results in death and destruction.
Yeah I think the Achilles heel it's that
deeply rooted drive for self-preservation.
I mean, ironically for survival on an,
On an individual level.
Yeah,
which i.e. selfishness.
And it's tricky 'cause
it's not just individual.
It's individual and then it's group.
But it's very difficult for the
empathy to spread outside of
the in-group.
The in-group and out-group mentality.
It's funny,
the irony of becoming super
connected through technology,
but not having developed the brain.
And I'm not saying this is
not how much stupidity or
intelligent, I'm just saying
our brains have not
developed to a place yet
where we actually can get out
of the ingroup and outgroup
thinking, all of us.
And the technology has
instead of connecting us
its enhanced the in
grouping and out grouping.
In a way that like,
we're more divided now than we ever were.
Like people, I saw a guy tweet.
He was a liberal dude, progressive dude.
And he was talking about how
his Trump supporting neighbor
was locked out of his
house and it was raining.
And he was like, he tweeted like
my Trump supporting neighbor is locked.
My MAGA neighbor is
locked out of his house.
What should I do?
Oh God.
And the people started like saying,
well you should just let him
sit out there in the rain
and all this stuff.
And I was just like,
how is this a question?
I don't care, honestly, I don't
care who the dude supports.
I mean, I may care and I may disagree.
But like, if my neighbor
is locked out of his house,
and needs me to help him,
needs me to call somebody.
That's what we should be doing.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we've lost the ability, we're like,
I'm not gonna help you
because I disagree with you politically.
Like, I'm not gonna help
you with a basic need.
Like what the hell has happened to people?
How is this even a question
and how is it that you can
ask this question on Twitter
and people, I mean, some people were like,
you should help the dude.
I mean, okay yeah you
disagree with him politically.
You may stand against
every value that he has,
but he's a human in need, help him.
You know, and I see
that and I'm just like,
that is not a lot of hope.
There's not a lot of hope.
And that to me it just
seems like common decency.
And I just don't get it. I
don't understand you know.
I've got lots of people in my life
who are gonna vote for Trump.
And I got lots of people in my life
who were gonna vote for Biden.
And I can have intelligent, you know,
respectable debate with them.
And I may like really, really, really
have strong opinions about this.
It may even get heated at times,
but the moment that they get hurt
or they need something basic
my connection to them as a fellow human
supersedes my political ideology.
And if it doesn't, we are doomed, doomed.
I thought you said this
was gonna get heavy.
All right, well at least we
just solved it, it's my rec.
I'm gonna try to turn it
back to something light.
I'm gonna recommend,
I'm gonna go back to
our board game episode.
Yeah good.
I talked about the board
game that I had ordered
called Parks.
So rec baby rec baby
one, two, three, four.
This is my recommendation.
You can get it at
Target, Barnes and Noble,
Amazon Parks by Key Master Games.
I had ordered it through
their Kickstarter campaign.
They raised like over
half a million dollars
to do the expansion pack
because this game is so popular.
And you know what?
It's not here yet
because I didn't order through
the places I just said.
My game arriving was delayed
until the expansion pack
was produced as well.
'Cause I joined this like a
higher level of Kickstarter.
'Cause that was just
excited to play a game
about national parks.
To hopefully get my kids into games
and national parks at the same time.
The artwork is really great.
The workmanship on these
things is really great.
I've already talked this up,
but then in the mail, I got the game.
Before the expansion pack is out.
And inside there was a note from
the people at Key Master Games.
They had heard our conversation about,
They sent you an early copy?
Yeah.
Because the game itself
is available other places.
And they had that in stock.
They went ahead and sent that to me,
along with like a
personalized note about having
heard our conversation
and like getting more kids
and families into playing games.
It was a very sweet.
I keep the letter from them in the game.
I paid for it, they didn't
give it to me for free.
I mean I didn't want it for free.
And this is not, again,
this is not a sponsor.
And I'm still waiting
on an expansion pack,
but we started to play it.
It was a little, it was
a bit of a learning curve
having not played a lot of games.
And then like the family,
they didn't have a lot of patience.
Chris was like, you know what,
why don't you like
Spend some time with this.
Why don't we put a pin in this.
Maybe you can watch a video that like
shows how to play the game
instead of you trying to figure it out
and teach us at the same time.
I was like, you know what? That's fair.
So we like, we reconvened,
I did some research,
I watched some play throughs.
And then I knew how to play the game.
Hot tip,
if you're gonna teach your
family how to play a game,
you should already know how to play it.
'Cause it could be-
Or maybe
just show them the video.
very slow and frustrating.
Well, I watched like an hour
and a half play through.
Okay.
I'm now that guy.
I watched board games
being played for an hour
and a half on YouTube.
That's what it took.
And then we played it.
And then last night after dinner,
Lily and Lando were like,
let's play Parks again.
Like the two of them
hardly ever wanna do the same thing.
And then we played again last night.
Very good game.
Well worth the 50 bucks
which you have to pay to get the game.
What is the object?
To visit parks
and have just an amazing experience
with lots of great memories.
Basically to have the most
number of points at the end of the game
by visiting the most parks.
And there's like resources involved.
How do you sabotage other players?
You can block them out of
getting to places on the hike
that they need to get to in order to
reach their personal goals in
order to rank up their points.
Isn't it funny if the object of the game
was just for everybody
to get what they wanted
and everybody to have a good
time you wouldn't enjoy it?
I mean, I'm just saying
Yeah.
the reason I asked that
question is because,
it goes back to the
conversation we just had.
There's something inside of us that we,
we don't want everybody to win.
We don't want everybody to win.
Only one person can win the
game and you have to, yeah.
You're trying to do everything
strategically in order to
yeah.
But that appeals to us.
To block people out.
That appeals to something
that is so deeply.
In other words, what I'm saying is,
and I'm not trying to be the downer.
Again I know you tried to bring it up.
But it may be that that mentality
is so deeply ingrained in us that
there is no scenario
where all of a sudden we become
nine, 10 billion people on a
planet and it's just a utopia.
Like maybe it's not possible.
Maybe there's always gotta be a winner
and always gotta be a loser.
It's something in our brains
that we are never gonna
be able to let go of,
unless there's some sort of deprogramming.
And so we're gonna build the population up
and then we're gonna decimate one another
and then it's gonna start again
and it's always gonna happen like that.
Well, I'll say because of
the artwork is so beautiful
and because it's about experiencing parks,
it feels better.
It feels better.
And like I enjoy
working my brain in order to strategize
to get as many points as possible.
But if I lose, I still find
myself being pretty happy.
Maybe the key-
Lincoln doesn't though.
I'll tell you.
He gets upset?
Lincoln in competitive.
Okay yeah, good for him.
Here's the thing, I'm very competitive
as we've established.
But yet I still want the
world to work together.
I want us to get to utopia.
But I just kind of feel like
there's not enough people on board.
And that's what I was trying
to say about celebrities.
It's like, in a lot of ways, I feel like
I've gotten what I want out of life.
It's like the Bill Gates of it all.
He's gotten what he wants out of life
and now he's devoted his time, his energy
and his massive resources to
making a positive difference.
It's like I'm not gonna say
You mean controlling.
You mean,
I'm not gonna say that
Controlling your mind and
manipulating your idea.
Does he have completely pure motives?
Does anybody? But like, he's one of them.
He's in a position that makes him,
I deam him more trustworthy.
And I feel like, honestly,
from my own experience.
I think that was mostly Melinda.
Okay.
I think she was the one who was like,
All right.
I think Bill,
Yeah.
We're the richest people on earth.
Let's do some good.
And I think she talked him into it.
That's kind of what I think.
I take it all back and
apply it to Melinda.
It is the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation
Yeah.
after all,
I was gonna make a statement
about alterior motives
and like figuring all that out.
But I don't want to go back there.
Just enjoy Parks, the board game.
Enjoy Parks and just
enjoy parks in general.
If you can get into one
Oh yeah do that.
Hash tag EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.